what's behind the surge in palestinian
attacks on israelis three incidents in a
week kill at least 11 people
could the upcoming holidays for
christians jews and muslims lead to more
shootings and stabbings this is inside
story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim jom more israeli soldiers
are being sent to the occupied west bank
in response to what the prime minister
calls a wave of terrorism a gunman shot
dead five people in an ultra-orthodox
jewish town on tuesday six others were
killed in two earlier attacks in tel
aviv and birsheva israeli security
forces say isil inspired the attackers
palestinian president mahmoud abbas
warned of repeat incidents as muslims
jews and christians prepare for ramadan
passover and easter harry fossett has
more from west jerusalem
the chaotic aftermath of a major attack
deep inside israel the third in just a
week this was banebarak a densely
populated ultra-orthodox town east of
tel aviv mobile phone footage showed
what had happened minutes earlier an
attacker on the street two apparent
victims already slumped nearby
brandishing a long-barreled gun
a cyclist narrowly escapes with his life
before the gunman confronts a driver
yelling at him to stop then shooting him
at close range
i saw a very difficult situation a
police motorbike that hit a wall and a
policeman next to it who was shot he
looked dead i took over the situation i
checked for gunshot wounds he'd been
injured
israeli police say amir khori the
injured officer who later died was the
one who shot the attacker dead he's been
named as diacha marche from near janine
in the occupied west bank reported to
have been working illegally at a
construction site in the area of the
attack israel's prime minister naftali
bennett convened an emergency security
meeting then warned of a new wave of
terror
this is a great and complex challenge
for the army the security agency and the
police that requires the security
establishment to be creative and for us
to adapt ourselves to the new threat and
read the tell-tale signs of lone
individuals sometimes without
organizational affiliation and to be in
control on the ground
last tuesday in the southern city of
bercheva a resident of a nearby bedouin
town killed four people in a car ramming
and stabbing attack before himself being
shot dead an israeli court had
previously convicted him on charges of
supporting isil on sunday two
palestinian israelis opened fire on a
street in hadera north of tel aviv
killing two security forces members
before they too were shot dead again
israeli authorities pointed to isil
ideology that attack was followed by
arrests in their home town part of a
heightened response including more use
of detention without charge surveillance
and police and military reinforcements
the fear is that this chain of attacks
could inspire yet more in an already
combustible period from gaza hamas and
palestinian islamic jihad have hailed
this latest shooting as they had the
previous attacks in recent days the
palestinian president mahmoud abbas
condemned the killing of civilians and
warned of the risks of a further
deterioration in stability those fears
are certainly shared by an israeli
government now dealing with the
deadliest week of attacks on its
citizens in many years harry fossett
al-jazeera west jerusalem
the shooter came from the town of yabad
in the occupied west bank
ibrahim sent us this update
while the palestinian president has
condemned the
killing of civilians people who have
been speaking to here and yeah but kim
say that the situation has already been
deteriorating because the president has
been saying that this killing of
civilians is going to be leading towards
a deterioration people talk about
expansion of settlements uh settler
attacks and even almost nightly raids by
the israeli army we're hearing now from
people behind us that the israeli army
is
back to yabad they've been here
overnight in the morning and again now
all in all
we have our sources saying that the
israeli army arrested 26 palestinians
including the brother of the
hamas we've spoken to his family and
they say they had no idea that he was
plotting anything he was having lunch
with them and then he left and that they
learned of what happened
in the news
[Music]
all right let's bring in our guests in
tel aviv you'll see mecklenburg senior
consulting research fellow at the
chatham house think tank
in dublin yasir
assistant professor at trinity college
dublin
and in london daniel levy president of
the u.s middle east project and former
israeli negotiator a warm welcome to you
all and thanks so much for joining us
today on inside story daniel let me
start with you today from your
perspective why are these attacks
happening now
look muhammad when when one has
individual attacks and and those should
be condemned and and i do condemn those
it's it's sometimes tricky to draw a
direct causal line in terms of the act
of the individual however
there is
almost an inevitability
that if one keeps conditions for the
palestinians in which there is permanent
dispossession occupation in which there
is a permanent
reality for palestinians where they
don't have basic rights and freedoms you
are going both at the popular level at
the collective level
to have efforts to
turn against that and you're going to
have at the individual level a depth of
frustration
desperation and despair which will
occasionally
lend itself to such actions and that is
the conducive environment which exists
and we see these things happen
periodically so if the reaction is
just to talk about
terrorism and securitize steps that need
to be taken and if there is no
mention and there hasn't been thus far
on the official israeli side and
unfortunately that's as one would expect
no recognition of the root causes of the
broader
circumstances conditions realities of
palestinian existence under israeli rule
across the entirety of the area where
israel rules then you simply set
yourself up for a repeat of this there
are other elements to this we're coming
into a holiday season for the three
monotheistic face we're very close to
the start of ramadan there has been an
uptick in frustrations sometimes if
there's an expectation that the
situation might improve and it doesn't
that can lead to an added layer of
frustration and i think one shouldn't
ignore and again i'm not drawing a
direct causal line but one shouldn't
ignore the extent of provocation
against palestinians being undertaken by
the region
recently
we just had secretary of state blinken
in a summit in the the negev the
knock-up with
certain representatives of arab states
who were basically saying
we don't
want to address the palestinian question
we're not interested in you some of them
may have given some rhetoric about this
but when you see this uae
israeli-american
abraham accords continued
unquestioningly
since its inception under trump i think
there's an added poking people in the
eye and and this was a mistake
yeah i said let me ask you a similar
question from your vantage point
what is it that's triggering these
attacks
well i think we need to put it in the
context of
long-term injustice and in the context
of occupation and in the context of
oppression
that the palestinians have been
experiencing since 1948 and before
palestinians have lost their land
they've lost their society and they're
suffering from occupation and
palestinians in gaza are under blockade
they have been under blockade since 2007
palestinians in the west bank
are also under occupation and they're
suffering from checkpoints from the wall
palestinians in jerusalem as well and
they're being
kicked out of their homes they're being
forced out of their homes palestinians
in israel as well are facing
discrimination and racism
and this is the context this is the
context of the palestinian experience
that we have to recognize it's an
experience and a story of dispossession
a story of injustice that they have
experienced and also a story of
occupation and colonialism and one has
to recognize this difficult reality for
the palestinians and i mean
unfortunately the international
community will not speak about the
palestinians unless there is some kind
of violent actions on the ground and
violence is not acceptable of course but
we need to talk about the original
context of the violence the the you know
the the root issues
that that have led to this violence and
have have led to these actions and those
root issues are still there they haven't
been addressed as i said since 1948 and
before that and that includes
palestinian rights
and that includes also palestinian
independence that includes palestinian
security palestinian security is as well
important and it needs to be discussed
international organizations a human
rights organization have come out in
recent weeks and including i'm talking
here about um
amnesty international human rights watch
and israeli human rights organizations
who've come out and said palestinians
are simply living under apartheid in the
occupied territories so this is really
the context that we need to understand
when we talk about the palestinian
experience
you'll see um let me shift to something
that daniel mentioned a couple of
moments ago um
the fact that these attacks
are happening the same week of this
summit that was held in israel with the
four arab nations with egypt bahrain
morocco the uae along with the u.s how
significant is this timing
yeah first of all i would like to join
what you said earlier and i think we
should condemn
the killing indiscriminately killing of
of civilians and others
on other side and definitely what i can
hear over the last seven days
i'm not so sure i think we make some
some assumptions that there is a sort of
a flow of communication
in which there is the direct connection
between for instance the summit
and and and and the and and the
terrorist attacks i think it's actually
what was mentioned by the to other
speakers is the bigger picture
it might be a direct connection it might
be it may be a more of a coincidence but
the reality is is the conditions on the
ground the root causes of of the
conflict and i say since yes there is an
element of again we we as as much as
we support many support the abraham
echoed the surgery we like to see
countries getting on with one another
but we'd like also to see how the
abrahamic court facilitates for
negotiation with the palestinians we
would like to see a peace process that
come because instead of looking for a
peace walkers from external ones from
the outside of the region actually see
that the summit like the one that took
place in the negev this week
won't be only paid lip service to
palestinians or the conditions that
palestinians live under the occupation
or the blockade in gaza but actually
set a plan with a clear timeline
in in in order to resolve once and for
all
this conflict that's we don't see and i
think whether it's directly connected to
what happened this week and the the
xiaomi
summit last week or not i think this
will
remain to be seen but what we think
really is to look what are the
conditions that lead for extremism
radicalization violence
to prosper
daniel how are the attacks that have
taken place this past week different
from attacks in the past and what kind
of a test is this going to be
domestically for prime minister naftali
bennett
first of all
we don't know this could subside
there is a sense
especially because of the timing because
this is so close to um
religious holidays also something we
haven't talked about
but
jerusalem itself and the arrangements
around jerusalem
as a source of tension
we're almost a year
since uh
what palestinians have often referred to
as the unity intifada since a an
outbreak an escalation
that started in jerusalem so israel
would be very well advised uh not
to
impose a heavy not to have a heavy
footprint uh in its um security and
policing arrangements uh in jerusalem
over the next period and of course we've
also seen uh
chef jaraka the evictions of palestinian
families in that sensitive spot uh in
jerusalem so
we don't know yet how different this is
one thing we have seen
is
that the first two attacks were claimed
uh by daesh
involved palestinian citizens of israel
uh yasser referred to the conditions of
structural discrimination and inequality
uh in which those citizens live it's a
it's a
it's a strange time almost for that
community when you have a party in the
government representing that community
a lot of resentment also uh towards that
so we don't know how different it's
going to be what we do know mohammed is
after a long period of rule under
netanyahu this is the first time we're
seeing this kind of hybrid bennett
coalition um
dealing with
with this and i think there is genuine
concern
that if bennett were to pursue the
extreme rhetoric
that he voiced in the past as his actual
policy response then he's lighting a
match then things will get even uh
more deeply into a spiral would be the
expectation so i think you've got you've
got a spectrum right you could have a
very
um ill-advised
very securitized israeli response you
could have business as usual which is
also pretty bad or you could have
something which
i fear is not even on the agenda which
is to say yup we've got to get to terms
with the immediacy immediacy of this but
maybe this is the moment to address the
deeper political grievance
and if we don't address that there's the
inevitability of more with that is not a
narrative one's hearing so i think this
will be a test for bennett and of course
what you will have
is a a very agitating
uh right wing opposition outside of the
government that will be
paying for blood to to use that term
yes
prime minister bennett said that we will
fight terror with perseverance
stubbornness and an iron fist so my
first question to you is what kind of a
response do you expect will be seen
from israel my second question to you is
are you also concerned that there will
be more attacks that the attacks that
have happened thus far will inspire more
attacks especially at such a fraught
time
well i mean in terms of israeli response
the kind of response that we have seen
over the years and the past decades has
has always
been about using military power against
the palestinians uh so um that has been
always the israeli response
and it's a response that military
response for me does not represent a
solution it represents a problem and and
it causes more problems on the ground
and because let's let's not forget that
the military response is also part of
the occupation structure and the israeli
military is in the palestinian
territories and it's
on a daily basis
it's the the israeli military is engaged
in
military action against the palestinians
is engaged in violence against the
palestinians so i think we need to put
that in context not to defend violence
violence is not acceptable of course on
any side and
or
you know at the international level as
well but really to understand this long
palestinian experience of living under
occupation basically what they've been
facing is a systematic system of
apartheid a systematic system of
occupation that has all this system has
always presented to the palestinians not
a deeper political response as your
speaker referred to but rather a
military response and that military
response for me is about increasing
injustice on the ground it's about also
increasing tension on the ground what we
need is a broader political and deeper
solution that would deal with the root
issues um
and that and those issues include
security of course and they include also
palestinian rights and we have to
recognize that now
you referred also in your question
to the israeli prime minister planet
um bennett is on record um saying that
he is opposed to palestinian rights he
is against palestinian rights he is
against palestinian statehood so i'm not
expecting a political response if you
like
from bennett i'm expecting a hard and
extreme right-wing response
um
and that's not going to help that it's
going to increase the tension and the
injustice on the ground well and
and it's a response as i said that
israel has tried in the past and the
problem hasn't gone away so that means
we need to try something
more just we need to strive something
that is more comprehensive and something
that will address the problem and in my
view what will address the problem is a
deeper political solution that will
facilitate palestinian rights and
security for all
you'll see is the fact that the
religious holidays of ramadan passover
and easter the fact that they're going
to be converging this year is that
something that's also leading to an
escalation of tensions
probably and their expectation of some
some increase in violence i don't think
at this level in in this sense i think
the security services here were
surprised
but interestingly enough the three
incidents though they have some
commonality the source of it are quite
different
the first incidence in beersheba was
actually carried out by by bedwin
the second one is actually from benos
from um which is a stronghold of the
islamist movement and the third one is
actually from the palestinians from in
the occupied territories from
janine from yavin so i think
we are trying to connect all the three
of us and no doubts you know that the
the conditions on the ground and the
lack of hope and horizon that was
mentioned
off of peace were mentioned by the other
speakers play a part but i think we
still need to there are no doubt
triggers that for us those of us who
deal day in day out with with this
conflict
we are not surprised not because we
would like to see violence is because we
keep warning that without a
comprehensive solution for the israeli
palestinian conflict violence is is
almost inevitable
and the the inability of the leadership
to do anything about
about this and then blame everyone when
it does happen is is is the waterfall of
it reality is enough to either to visit
the west bank and to see the complete
apathy
on the other side of the green line when
it comes to the life of palestinians and
saying there is a
nato divide and then the international
community is is completely
disinterested and that's sadly those are
the reminders now as for how israel is
going to react sadly i think
this kind of situation there will be
overreaction you you you won't expect
the israeli security forces especially
this sensitive time of the holidays not
to respond to this because
as
as i said myself here in right now in
tel aviv you don't know whether god
forbid is the next dex attack so you
will see
the presence of more security forces in
the streets
but the question if there is an ability
to move away just from security response
from using more force and then there
will be more palestinian victims as a
result of it and probably on the other
side too or to do something else the sad
reality for just may end is on both
sides there are very weak administration
very weak governments and we governments
tend to overreact instead of actually
being reflective
daniel it looked like you wanted to jump
in i'm going to let you do that but but
i also want to ask you um
what i seem to be hearing in one form or
another from from you from yossi and
from yasir is that really things aren't
going to change unless there's a real
look at the root causes of what's going
on and an attempt at a comprehensive
solution so let me ask you is there any
hope right now that that is something
that can actually be achieved
well i i i unfortunately can can give
you a relatively categorical and clear
response on on that last point which is
no we're not in the solution zone
there is
no willingness on the israeli side to
end
the occupation to end what human rights
organizations have designated as a
reality of apartheid
in the system which uh which prevails
and you have and this is this is also
a a a significant problem you have a
palestinian authority
that
has
distanced itself so much
from its people that has not allowed
itself to be held accountable by its
people in elections etc and that is very
widely viewed as a subcontractor
for the israeli authorities and is
therefore not in a position to rally its
people in in one direction or another
but where i wanted to to to intervene
specifically is
is that
if there is this overreaction if we now
do get into a cycle what what we've seen
in these three attacks
indiscriminate on civilians
categorically
unacceptable but once you get into a
broader escalation then one has to be
reminded of the fact that palestinians
have a legitimate right and even
responsibility to resist this military
occupation and i say that in the context
of the daily commentary and pictures
that we see coming out of ukraine and
suddenly when people are
stockpiling molotov cocktails they are
being lauded as heroic courageous
patriots if you do that while
palestinian
you are almost always declared a
terrorist
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thank you so much to
all of our guests you'll see mecklenburg
and daniel levy
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jroom and the whole team
here in doha bye for now
[Music]